das ist schon etwas seltsam da gibt es
in einer galaxie mit einem besonders
stern reichen und dichten zentrum doch
es fehlt das schwarze loch denn das ist
inzwischen klar wie bei einem
sternensystemen die planeten um den
zentralen stern kreisen drehen sich
galaxien um ein schwarzes loch in ihrer
mitte immer eigentlich hier fehlt es in
diesem fall
wieso weshalb warum das erfahrt ihr hier
bei pixum future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannen des seins videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
dann verpasst er nicht los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
pixum gehört zu den erfolgreichen
wissenschafts podcast in deutschland
jedes thema gibt es auch auf die ohren
wer also manchmal keine augen sondern
nur um 5 ticks um hat der sollte hier
auf sie klicken es ist quasi so als
würde ein atomkraftwerk ohne reaktor
laufen in dieser galaxie fehlt einfach
das schwarze loch im zentrum
es geht um die zentrale galaxien
galaxienhaufen abell tutu sechs wochen
genauer um die galaxie aid to six waren
wie sie die ihr zentrum ist dicht und
voller sterne also genau der fall bei
dem eigentlich ein schwarzes loch im
zentrum der galaxie sein sollte ist es
aber nicht masse mindestens 10
milliarden sonnenmassen sollte es
eigentlich haben und die forschenden
untersuchten das zentrum mit dem hubble
weltraumteleskop mit radioteleskopen
aber pustekuchen nichts nur eine 50
millionen jahren ältere radio emission
störte das very large telescope auf also
nichts was auf ein schwarzes loch
hinweisen würde das ist schon ziemlich
verrückt denn ohne ein schwarzes loch
ist diese galaxie einfach nicht denkbar
es sorgt eben für das helle strahlende
zentrum in der mitte von spiralgalaxien
dabei entsteht das leuchtenden zentrum
der galaxien nicht durch eine
thermonukleare fusion wie etwa im
sternen inneren stattdessen sorgten die
schwarzen löcher im zentrum von solchen
galaxien dafür dass die zentren so hell
sind und so viel strahlung abgeben
diese schwarzen löchern sitzen in der
mitte von galaxien und sind super
massereich etwa so schwer wie ein paar
millionen sonnen oder in diesem fall
sogar von milliarden sonnenmassen
eigentlich ein bisschen so als würde man
einen laufenden kernreaktor untersuchen
in dem aber der reaktorkern fehlt nur in
einer galaxie passiert etwas anderes im
zentrum materie in form von gas und
sterne nähert sich dem zentralen
schwarzen loch
und es bewegt sich zunächst um dieses
herum und damals als es sich tierisch
auf in spiralförmigen bahnen wandert die
materie immer weiter auf das loch zu
eine scheibe aus staub und gas um gibt
also das schwarze loch und wird dabei
extrem heiß und leuchtet dabei extrem
hell
dadurch dass das schwarze loch im
aktiven galaxienkernen also gigantische
mengen an materie einsaugt und dadurch
energie in form von strahlung abgibt
leuchtet das zentrum zu hält bei unserer
milchstraße regen ist es etwas anders
das schwarze loch ist hier so gut wie
gar nicht aktiv da es also nicht viel
los wenn bei uns also kein schwarzes
loch zu finden sein würde dann würde das
vielleicht ein achselzucken verursachen
aber auch nicht mehr
bei 26 von bcg ist das alles höchst
seltsam denn das ist anders kann
gültekin von der university of michigan
und sein team testeten mit dem chandra
weltraumteleskops zentrum der galaxie ab
und auch die sternenhaufen im umfeld
nichts deutete auf ein schwarzes loch
hin aber wie kann das sein wo ist es hin
denn das ist ein schwarzes loch gegeben
haben muss dass es sicher ohne ein
schwarzes loch könnte es nicht an derart
dichtes und sternen reiches zentrum
geben es gibt einen verdacht und der ist
gigantisch wenn zwei galaxien zentren
korrigieren wie es bei uns und der
andromeda galaxie in rund vier
milliarden jahren der fall sein wird
dann kollidieren auch die schwarzen
löcher in deren zentren wenn sie das
asymmetrisch tun wenn also ein schwarzes
loch zum beispiel mehr geschwindigkeit
hat oder mehr masse hat oder beides dann
kann das verschmolzene schwarze loch aus
dem galaxien kann herauskatapultiert
werden
bei einer corsa galaxie kann man einen
solchen sehr speziellen fall sogar
beobachten bei dem basar freesie onex
liegt das zentrum der galaxie neben ihr
und damit auch das schwarze loch ist
wurde aus der galaxie herauskatapultiert
die ursache sehen forschende in der
kollision zweier galaxien belegt ist das
noch nicht aber auch bei ipv6 waren bcg
gibt es hinweise
genau ein solches ereignis nicht nur das
der galaxien kern außergewöhnlich dicht
ist er hat ein loch der dichte teil des
zentrums mit vielen sternen beginnt erst
2000 lichtjahre vom eigentlichen zentrum
entfernt im zentrum selbst ist nichts
absolute leere und das zentrum hat noch
mehr sehr seltsame eigenschaften die für
eine kollision
zweier galaxien mit dem herausschleudern
des zentralen schwarzen lochs verbunden
sein könnten
das sich besonders viele sterne im
zentrum befinden könnte für die
kollision sprechen die dann so viele
sterne im zentrum erklärt und noch etwas
ist absolut mysteriös das zentrum der
galaxie ist gar nichts das zentrum der
kern von aid to six the city ist 2200
lichtjahre gegenüber der eigentlichen
mitte der galaxie verschoben sind die
seltsamen eigenschaften der galaxie also
das ergebnis der kollision und
verschmelzung zweier galaxien dass das
nichts besonderes ist sieht man an
unsere galaxie wir leben nämlich in
einer galaxie die aus zwei galaxien
besteht rund 30.000 untersuchte sterne
in unserer milchstraße sind nämlich ganz
anders als alle anderen sterne in der
galaxie sie bewegen sich entgegengesetzt
zu einem großen teil der sterne und auch
ihre chemische zusammensetzung ist
anders und das wirklich ihre daran diese
anderen sterne haben sehr ähnliche
eigenschaften und 13 kugelsternhaufen
mit diesen gleichen eigenschaften gibt
es allein in halo der milchstraße also
dem riesigen kugelförmigen bereich rund
um die scheibe unserer galaxie der
schluss diese sterne und sternenhaufen
im halo stammen alle aus der gleichen
galaxie und zwar nicht aus unserer
heimat galaxien
früher dachte man noch dass sich dort
draußen reste von zwerggalaxien befinden
würden aber dass dort gleich eine ganz
andere galaxie zu finden ist darüber war
die astrophysik dann doch überrascht
offenbar gab es vor zehn milliarden
jahren einen riesigen crash zwischen
unserer milchstraße und an einer anderen
galaxie woraus sich dann unsere galaxie
in der heute bekannten form bildete die
milchstraße ist nämlich in der mitte
zehn mal dicker bisher war völlig unklar
warum dieser dicke teil wurde durch den
crash wesentlich mitverursacht und das
erkennt auch wahrscheinlich das
mysteriöse flattern unserer galaxie sie
tut das nämlich in nord süd richtung
also senkrecht zu ihrer drehachse bzw
parallel das ist nach dem stand der
wissenschaft das nachschwingen dieses
crashs damals drang die fremde galaxie
von oben oder unten in die milchstraße 1
und baute sie erst in die eine richtung
aus durch gravitation wurden sie wieder
zurückgezogen und wollte die galaxie in
die andere richtung aus und noch heute
ist dieser prozess in form des
nachschwingen zu beobachten die
schwarzen löcher der beiden
aktien sind dabei dann verschmolzen aber
eben symmetrisch was dazu führte dass
das schwarze loch sagittarius stern noch
weiter in der mitte unserer galaxie
sterne frist sehr langsam aber immerhin
spricht die kollision zweier galaxien
ist also gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich
die forscher schließen daraus dass aid
to six von bcg vor etwa zehn millionen
jahren mit einer anderen galaxie
kollidiert und verschmolzen ist um die
supermassereichen schwarzen löcher in
ihren zentren wurden aus dem zentrum der
neuen galaxie gesteigert allerdings
müsste dieses schwarze loch gar nicht
die galaxie verlassen haben sondern
könnte sich immer noch in der nähe des
galaxien kerns befinden
wenn dann im herbst diesen jahres das
mega weltraumteleskop das james webb
weltraumteleskop endlich startet soll
das mit seiner gigantischen auflösung
und schafe in richtung des
galaxienhaufens abell to six anschauen
vielleicht findet es ja irgendwo da
draußen spuren des schwarzen loches von
asics von bcg und kann das rätsel
endlich lösen wenn ihr also in zukunft
war unterwegs seid keine lust auf ein
video habt oder oder oder
hier geht es zum podcast einfach
draufklicken unsere skripte sind
speziell so geschrieben dass sie mit und
ohne videofunktion ihren ich versuche
wirklich immer alles möglichst gut zu
beschreiben ich freue mich sehr über
jeden und jede zu hörende vielen dank
dass ihr dabei seid bis dann bleibt dran